[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas manqué si vous êtes un
passionné de sport local aujourd'hui
comme toujours il y aura des analystes
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau ils sont en pleine
forme présentation en musique de cette
magnifique équipe équipe on commence à
ma droite musique il est de retour dans
cette émission c'est un pistard de
niveau international il a été champion
du monde de cyclisme sur piste master
s'il est spécialistes cyclisme et plus
encore le capitaine gagne est avec lui
pendant Hubert bonsoir Monsieur le
come-back et oui ça fait ça oui c'est ma
première de l'année alors c'est bizarre
puisque YouTube là toutes les tous les
15 jours mais oui ça fait ça fait
plaisir de pouvoir revenir parmi vous
parce que je précise vous travaillez à
côté malheureusement la chaîne ne me
paye pas assez pour que je puisse me
faire que cela le message est passé
alors continue à tour de table à gauche
musique il est encore une une fois
présent dans cette émission c'est l'un
des meilleurs journalistes sur le sport
italien et sur le sport yvelinois tout
le monde se l'arrache milite avec nous
sur ce plateau notre Italian lover
Grégory canalet est avec nous bonjour
Michael bonjour à tous ça fait bizarre
de poisson retourner d'habitude on a le
petit mouvement
on est nombreux on est nombreux
comment allez-vous bah écoutez très bien
je reviens actuellement de Nantes où
j'ai pu assister à une belle victoire de
mon club de cœur la Juventus face à
Nantes et je tenais à rendre hommage au
public nantais ce stade de la Beaujoire
incandescent qui chantait même après le
3-0 infligé par la Juventus une brigade
Loire qui est au rendez-vous franchement
c'était un super moment de sport un
super moment que j'ai vécu bravo à la
Juventus et bravo à Nantes qui a quand
même tenu à dragées haute quand même à
la à la Juventus de Turin on repasse de
l'autre côté musique c'est notre
spécialiste rugby mais ici connaît dans
tous les sports c'est l'un des maillons
forts de cette émission il est toujours
aussi élégant et déterminé notre
gladiateur Pierre Chevalier du Rugby
Club de Versailles nous fait l'honneur
de venir cette émission forme et bonheur
à tous salut votre musique qui a retenti
sur ce plateau
romaine
ça sent le printemps ça sent le
printemps effectivement avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de belles de belles
confrontations plein de sport plein de
résultats commentaires et on attend
quand même le retour de la chaleur parce
qu'il fait quand même frère quand même
sur les terrains tout va bien alors on
passe de l'autre côté musique c'est une
légende vivante et on a la chance de la
voir à chaque fois ou presque sur ce
plateau c'est coup de gueule son
mythique ces analyses sont à chaque fois
pertinentes il est l'essence même de ce
talk coach genre Miss ex entraîneur de
plaisir est avec nous des bonjour à tous
Comment allez-vous
impeccable l'essence mais à prix bas
sur le souligner voilà 99 on termine de
l'autre côté musique c'est un petit
nouveau ilonore sa troisième sélection
dans cette émission il est resp
sponsoring chez Orange en Île-de-France
il adore le sport il vibre pour le sport
mesdames et messieurs Philippe volak
nous fait l'honneur de venir dans cette
émission bonjour à tous un plaisir de
revenir pour la troisième fois et là je
reviens en plus d'un classico du
classico donc c'était on parlait de
Nantes c'était un camp descend mais là
c'était aussi mais
que j'ai les avis de climatisés
[Musique]
et vous vous emmener généralement les
jeunes c'est ça sur le port du terrain
non pas sur le bord du terrain sur le
sur le terrain pour l'orange Football
Challenge et c'est des équipes de 13 à
15 ans de toute l'Île-de-France bus 78
aussi bien sûr et voilà donc il tire au
but et c'est un moment merveilleux pour
eux et des étoiles plein les yeux et ça
fait super plaisir de voir ses sourires
alors avant de au programme de
l'émission on va parler de cyclisme le
Paris-Nice partira ce weekend depuis les
Yvelines pour la 14e fois consécutive ce
dimanche 5 mars les coureurs partiront
de la verrière pour une boucle dans les
Yvelines le lendemain c'est la fille
petite commune de bazinville qui
accueillera les sportif justement du
côté des sportifs le plateau sera relevé
il y aura le vainqueur du dernier Tour
de France Yonas Wingard il y aura
également tadage poggatchard vainqueur
de deux tours de France et
malheureusement il n'y aura pas égal
Bernal on l'a on l'a appris il y a
quelques instants avant de rentrer sur
ce plateau mais il y aura des Français
comme Robin romain Bardet ou encore
Arnaud démarre la question sur cette
thématique cette édition
s'annonce-t-elle prometteuse oui ou non
vu le plateau oui on est tous d'accord
sur ce plateau jean ou qui est un
passionné de cyclisme tout à fait Arnaud
est mort c'est tout va bien
non mais forcément plus le plateau et
prestigieux plus plus la compétition
elle est donc forcément avec tous les
tous les langues que vous venez de citer
ben ça va faire un joli Parini une belle
répétition pour pour le Tour de France
et on sait que c'est une des plus belles
classiques donc que demander de plus
quoi le Tour de France qui partira aussi
du vélo de la semaine de 50 ans en
Yvelines ce sera perdu en juillet
prochain les Yvelines terres du cyclisme
on a toujours dit ici Philippe qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez je trouve que en plus
le la semaine et les très bien en plus
il y a des il y a pour tout le monde il
y a des sprinters des des baroudeurs il
y a aussi un contre-la-montre par équipe
il y en avait pas eu un depuis je crois
1993 je crois et en plus si c'est ça et
en plus nouveau ils prennent le temps
que sur le premier et plus sur le
quatrième comme il faisait comme il
faisait tout le temps et puis le
derrière étape
15 km de monter là je pense que ça va
ouais c'est pas mal on va voir un beau
beau Paris Nice Pierre Chevalier vous
aussi qui est spécialiste
cyclistes exactement amateur d'avoir
l'éternel oui tout à fait on roule le
dimanche ensemble avec Jeannot et puis
beaucoup de place sur la route
ça lance idéalement la saison je dirais
la saison médiatique parlons-en la
saison médiatique et les spectaculaire
des classiques de cyclisme genre à
rappeler évidemment le point d'orgue
avec le Tour de France mais que ce soit
en France en Île-de-France et plus
particulièrement dans les Yvelines un
plateau comme celui-là avec avec assez
peu d'absents dans le dans le gotha le
gotha mondial actuel c'est un gage de
couverture maximum pour la partie
médiatique pour les spectateurs c'est et
les amateurs de cyclistes de cyclisme il
y en a c'est idéal aussi pour justement
pour être au bord au bord des routes sur
les villes étapes au départ donc ça va
lancer idéalement cette cette presse
saison
olympique alors on n'est pas sur la
piste mais sur la route ça va être ça va
être quelque chose
Grégory
la parole ensuite au spécialistes
qui trépigne d'impatience non moi juste
rajouter que oui forcément le plateau
s'annonce on va dire ambitieux on a
envie de suivre ce Paris-Nice parce
qu'en plus il part des Yvelines et on
avait ce duel au dernier tour de France
entre pogaccha et vinghorn donc il y a
tourné à la faveur du danois espérons
qu'on va le revoir aussi même si c'est
le début de saison qu'on est seulement
voilà qui a l'entame de cette saison de
de cyclisme avec cette première vraiment
grosse compétition qui arrive pourquoi
pas et bien avoir un très très beau duel
sur sur la route donc on peut forcément
que se satisfaire d'avoir ces deux
grands champions et les autres aussi à
côté pour ce Paris-Nice
à votre avis pourquoi pas je sais pas si
il fera dès le Paris-Nice mais pourquoi
pas oui avoir avoir ça peut en tout cas
annoncer un beau duel pour le prochain
Tour de France je pense le spécialiste
cyclisme maintenant il y a déjà
football
alors ils sont bons alors du coup
confirmez
[Musique]
alors là où je je pense que
habituellement sur d'autres saisons je
n'aurais pas dit ce que je vais dire là
tout simplement parce que habituellement
on se dit oui on est début mars le Tour
de France est très loin encore il y a
largement le temps sauf que avec le
début de saison que poggatchard et que
vin de garde vienne de faire c'est à
dire que dès leur première course ils
ont ils ont ils ont marqué
pogaccha a gagné trois étapes deux ou
trois étapes sur sa sur sa première
course à étape plus le général d'une
garde pareil une étape plus en général
sur sur sa première course à étape donc
du coup là j'ai quand même l'impression
que c'est un peu le round de 1 avant le
Tour de France du mois de juillet qui va
être le feu d'artifice qui va être le
vert malheureusement une petite
répétitions avec un bémol c'est que
dommage et qui va pas y avoir de round
de 2 entre le tour d'eux entre Paris
Nice et Tour de France ça c'est un peu
plus un peu plus un peu dommage parce
que en effet ça aurait peut-être
inversé par la suite et par rapport à ce
que tu disais sur le contre par équipe
c'est vrai que du coup je pense que vin
de garde va avoir un avantage par
rapport à par rapport à poggatchard
parce que l'équipe de
[Musique]
l'équipe de vigne garde j'ai bouffé le
nom c'est pas grave ils sont en jaune et
ils ont rejoint habituellement et donc
et bien donc c'est quand même une grosse
équipe de rouleurs et je pense que
si la Jumbo fait
une vraie une grosse équipe pour pour ce
contre la menthe ça risque de faire la
différence pour pour la suite parce que
sur une course d'une semaine on a quand
même très peu de temps pour se pour se
rattraper par la suite et ce sont
souvent des des courses qui se jouent à
quelques secondes à quelques secondes
sur le dernier tour de France ou
pogatcher c'était retrouver un petit peu
esseulé et attaquer de toutes parts par
l'équipe du dernier vainqueur dimanche
au départ la verrière moi je
travaillerai
pas
drôle de papa dimanche donc
je sais pas c'est le rugby dimanche
sur les terrains je vais essayer de
m'organiser c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas fait c'est pas cher on aura
peut-être le plaisir de vous voir sur le
bord des routes alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de Neymar qui agace ses voisins à
Bougival mais également la direction
parisienne nous parlerons aussi de la
pépite du basket français les Vinois
Victor webanyama il ne veut pas être un
joueur lambda de NBA mais avant de
parler de ces thématiques on va parler
des JO de 2024
[Musique]
dans cette thématique on va parler des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 un peu plus
d'une semaine après l'ouverture deux
semaines après ouverture de la
billetterie on entend de nombreuses
critiques sur le prix des places pour
assister à cet événement planétaire les
prix des billets font effectivement
grincer les dents du côté des fans
pourtant selon le comité d'organisation
un tiers de ces précieux ces âmes sont
disponibles au tarif de 24 euros avec
l'objectif de partager les émotions
uniques des Jeux Olympiques 50% des
billets seraient accessibles au grand
public à 50 euros ou moins dans les
faits il faut déjà avoir été tiré au
sort jusqu'au 15 mars et ensuite il faut
composer son pack avec trois sports dans
la limite de 30 places alors on va
regarder le tarif pour les épreuves qui
concernent les Yvelines pour le BMX
Racing donc les images qui se déroulera
à 50 ans en Yvelines les tarifs
commencent à 24 euros mais grimpe
rapidement à 50 euros 90 euros et 120
euros pour le cyclisme sur piste
Vélodrome national on est entre eux 24
et 18 pour le VTT sur la colline
d'Élancourt on est à 24 euros le golf
c'est entre 24 et 150 euros pour
l'équitation on est entre 24 et 150
euros vous l'aurez compris les prix
peuvent monter à très vite et certains
sports affichent déjà complet dans les
Yvelines selon nos informations il y a
le BMX Racing qui serait complet en
soirée quasiment complet pour
l'équitation et le cyclisme sur piste la
question sur cette thématique êtes-vous
déçu par le système de billetterie mis
en place oui ou non
pour vous à Grégory Jean il faut vous
décider oui non
on va faire un petit duel entre vous
Yann et vous Grégory alors vous vous
êtes pas surpris en fait je suis pas
surpris d'être déçu un tout petit peu
mais pas surpris parce que bah je me
doutais que dans ce système de tirage au
sort forcément bah les premiers qu'elle
est tirés au sort aller se jeter sur les
places les plus intéressantes
effectivement on a beaucoup communiqué
du côté du comité d'organisation sur ces
places qui commencent à un tarif de 24
euros on reste quand même sur une
épreuve olympique ou forcément sur
certains sports l'athlétisme notamment
mais il y en a d'autres bah les prix
peuvent grimper très vite et forcément
dans ce système de tirage au sort j'ai
pas été surpris de voir que très vite
bah les premières places sont partis les
gens qui ont été qui ressort moi ça a
été le cas j'ai été tir au sort
avant-hier mon slot s'arrête là mais
plus trop de choix sur sur les sports
disponibles et forcément bah les places
qui restent c'est les places les plus
chers et en plus sur les sports
disponibles on parle même des preuves
qualification par le même pas des
épreuves on va dire du du déroulement
général des épreuves donc ça va être de
plus en plus compliqué ma chance est
passée sur ce tirage au sort j'espère
être tiré au sort sur les places uniques
parce que là on parle d'un système de
Pâques il y aura des places uniques
aussi à acheter il y aura un système de
tirage au sort qui sera mis en place un
peu plus tard donc déçu allez un tout
petit peu mais je suis pas surpris parce
que bah forcément on est entier au sort
en dernier bah on a les dernières places
et celles qui restent sont les plus
chères et vous alors vous êtes déçu il y
a du Jarrier par le déçu
avoir de place à un tarif abordable moi
mon slot c'était la semaine dernière il
a peut-être le mercredi c'est ça donc
une semaine après le début d'ouverture
la veille j'ai un copain qui a pu avoir
des places pour pour le VTT donc du coup
il était tout fier de mettre ses plats
sur sur Facebook et en plus on me
connaît c'est Olivier qui était déjà
venu sur le plateau pour pour parler de
pour parler des lots avec nous sur un
pari d'ici à 3-4 et euh et donc je me
dis bon bah c'est cool demain je vais
pouvoir prendre des places pour le VTT
et on ne m'a absolument pas proposé de
pouvoir prendre le VTT donc ça veut dire
que bah il y a plus de place donc
malheureusement le VTT c'est complet mes
enfants font de la clé donc j'ai voulu
regarder l'athlétisme alors je lui avais
déjà les informations en amont c'est à
dire que pour les places à 24 € c'était
que pour les sessions de l'après-midi ou
du matin comme on dit mais voilà donc
les sessions qualificatives l'après-midi
ou pour voir une finale sur une soirée
c'était minimum 85 euros il y avait rien
il y avait rien en dessous moi j'étais
prêt à faire à faire l'effort parce que
mes enfants font de l'atelier je voulais
la refaire découvrir les JO bah quand
j'ai regardé c'était 200 balles par
personne bah il y a un moment c'est plus
possible quoi comme vous voulez y aller
avec avec deux enfants c'est c'est
vraiment plus jouable
et puis et puis après cette
problématique en effet c'est à dire que
vous avez un sport donc la clé à 200
euros mais derrière faut encore aller
chercher d'autres deux autres sports
pour pouvoir compléter votre pack donc
c'est plus vous êtes plus à 600 balles
vous êtes à
1000 balles 1000 euros pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir aller voir trois sports et là je
suis désolé en cette période où les prix
ou les prix flambent pour pour tout ben
on peut pas on peut pas sortir 1000
euros pour un sport pour aller voir un
événement plus qui aura lieu dans un an
dans un an et demi donc mobiliser 1000
euros de trésorerie en ce moment ben je
suis désolé mais c'est c'est pas
possible donc voilà c'est vrai que un
peu déçu un peu déçu mais comme la di
Grégory c'est vrai que de toute façon il
n'y aura pas de système de billetterie
idéal pour ce genre d'événement il y
aura toujours des déesses il y aura
toujours il y aura toujours eu il y aura
toujours cette cette frustration mais
c'est vrai que quand on reçoit le mail
disant vous êtes tirés au sort et puis
moi j'ai eu le mail relativement tôt et
je me disais ouais c'est cool je sors
dans les sorts dans les premiers parce
que c'était il y a une semaine j'étais
super content je me dis ouais c'est bon
on va les avoir les sésame à 24 euros
bah non et non donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle et c'est vrai quand on reçoit
ce mail on a l'impression que ouais ça y
est on les allait bien
donc vous êtes vous êtes déçu et plutôt
convaincu aussi par Grégory il a réussi
à découvrir
que voilà au mois de mai j'espère
pouvoir aller chercher une place quoi
voilà pierre qui vous a convaincu ils
ont ils ont tous les deux abordés des
arguments des arguments faites
différents et donc et donc les les deux
sauvages côté côté Grégory d'accord avec
lui ça reste de toute façon ça reste un
business c'est un peu aussi comme la
Coupe du monde de rugby cette année qui
a eu le même le qui a connu le même
problème de perception en fait de
l'ouverture de la billetterie qui est
qui c'est qui est apparu assez
inéquitable et Yann lui évoqué le côté
ce qu'on nous avait vendu c'est à dire
un des jeux pour tous et qui un an et
demi avant le
1 an et demi et moins avant l'événement
ne permettent pas effectivement à tout
le monde d'avoir la trésorerie
disponible pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
avoir des billets parce qu'en plus il y
a cette imposition là comme il y avait
comme il y avait sur le pour la Coupe du
monde de rugby avec des packs et donc en
fait c'est une imposition un petit peu
de d'un choix à faire et surtout en fait
d'une addition de budget par rapport à
un sport auquel on voulait assister et
puis on est obligé de rajouter deux
options qui qui rajoutent qui rajoute
dans le budget dans le panier dans le
panier global donc au final je suis
plutôt du côté des déçus parce que c'est
on nous avait on nous avait vendus on
nous avait promis des jeux pour tous et
que ça allait être justement une
occasion de rassembler vraiment la
France du sport et de tous les sports
autour de cette de ce magnifique
événement la planète entière également
aussi puisqu'on l'accueille à côté de ça
je suis aussi conscient que c'est que
c'est un gros business que c'est un ce
sont des budgets énormes que sur les 40
dernières années quasiment tous les
comités d'organisation ont été
déficitaires sur l'organisation des Jeux
donc il faut essayer de trouver tous les
moyens pour tous les moyens possibles
pour amortir les nombreux travaux qu'il
faut faire pour
pour pouvoir faire sortir les stades de
terre sachant qu'en plus en France il y
en avait déjà pas mal d'utilisables mais
donc voilà donc c'est le ce juste milieu
qui qui est effectivement comme tu le
rappelais très dur à trouver desceptif
parce que mine de rien n'a quand même si
on fait le tour autour de ce plateau là
il y en a pas mal qui ont été tiré au
sort parce que on est on est au moins 4
à avoir été tirés au sort sur 6 donc
forcément ok mais quand même et je pense
que les participations étaient bien bien
supérieurs donc donc ils essayent quand
même de manière algorithmique de donner
celle de donner leur chance à tout le
monde après maintenant il faut avoir les
budgets en fait en réfléchissant c'est à
dire que on paye maintenant enfin on
achète maintenant nos billets pour un
événement pour aller dans 18 mois bah
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu proposer de
pouvoir payer en 10 fois
la trésorerie elle aurait été de toute
façon là avant que les jeux se les jeux
se déroulent en effet 1000 balles vous
payez 100 euros tous les mois pendant 10
mois bah ça aurait été plus plus facile
et on aurait peut-être moins j'aurais
peut-être moins moins réfléchi et je me
suis dit bah oui c'est bon on peut
largement le faire là c'était pas
c'était pas la période et en effet je
pense qu'il y a peut-être il y aura
peut-être eu cette cet élément là
qu'aurait pu être bien pensé et là
rendre justement les jeux accessibles à
tous et pour la billetterie c'est
environ 1,5 milliards qui sont prévus au
niveau du budget rien qu'avec la
billetterie donc logiquement 12000 € à
atteindre 1,5 milliards à la fin de la
phase de vente Philippe qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez enfin moi je suis
d'accord quand même un peu avec les avec
les deux mais bon moi tous ceux qui ont
été dire au sort ils sont tous déçus
donc j'en ai pas eu enfin sur ce que je
connais et moi j'étais au tiré au sort
j'ai reçu le mail juste avant l'émission
j'ai pas encore vu ce que je voulais
avoir mais
vraiment non non je suis déçu c'est vrai
qu'il y a 12 millions de billets qui
vont être mis en vente il y en a un
million à 24 euros 5 millions donc à 50
euros et moins donc ça fait moi il aura
fallu
accessibles à 50 euros et au moins et
donc moi je pense qu'il aura fallu
répartir il va encore avoir là il y a à
partir de 15 mai
pour voir le hand un match de Han et
savoir lequel c'est de voir je sais pas
quoi comme tu es pas fait les équipes ne
sont pas faites on sait pas ce qu'on va
aller voir c'est ça donc non je suis bon
je suis déçu et d'accord avec Grégory
parce que prévoir puisque la Coupe du
monde de rugby c'est pareil et la Coupe
du monde quand il y a eu de foot aussi
c'était c'est pareil aussi et le roux
aussi et l'euro encore plus près mais il
y a un moyen de jouer collectif aussi et
c'est c'est la chance que j'ai eu c'est
comme c'est par Pâques et il y a il peut
y avoir avec des amis ou de la famille
des gens intéressés par différents
sports et j'ai eu la chance par un
copain d'avoir des places pour le golf
lui ça l'intéressait moins il pistait le
rugby à 7 et finalement on s'est arrangé
et puis il m'a pris des places pour le
pour le golf et et on s'arrange en
jouant en équipe c'est du lien social
émulation globale des Jeux Olympiques
genre on vous a pas entendu sur la
question
est-ce que vous avez déjà été tiré au
sort je peux être des tiré au sort
quand je vois le bazar que c'est pour
rester poli pour rester poli
c'est commercial à tout donc forcément
ce système de pas qu'on s'est
pertinemment que c'est pour gagner de
l'argent dans un premier temps ça c'est
sûr les places d'appel à 24 euros moins
de 50 euros pour 50% des des places sauf
que dans le pack vous prenez ça un sport
une disciplingo vous intéresser on vous
oblige à me prendre deux autres qui vous
intéresse pas du tout et vous êtes allez
obliger de mettre quand même un billet à
l'arrivée ça fait un gros billet et tout
ça c'est commercial et malheureusement
tous ces cette publicité avec ce sport
pour tous ces prix d'appel de 24 euros
tout ça c'est pour amorcer un peu tout
le monde ces tirages au sort c'est quand
même la compétition planétaire c'est pas
facile non plus
et c'est normal que des déçu ça c'est la
normalité par contre c'est vrai qu'il
faut pas surtout pas oublier que c'est
commercial et que il faut tout pour
rapporter le plus d'argent pour en
perdre le moins à arriver et après ton
histoire dit que ce sont à peu près les
mêmes tarifs qu'à Londres
je dis pas je dis pas que nous on fait
mieux au moins bien que les autres on
fait dans la même lignée que que ce qui
a été toujours fait parce qu'un corps
une fois Pierre elle a dit tout à
l'heure mais c'était un événement qui
qui est déficitait pour les
organisateurs depuis depuis pas mal de
temps donc forcément il faut essayer
d'en perdre moins possible donc on est
obligé de faire comme ça il y a pas de
il y a pas de de formule magique après
dans la communication ils ont été
vraiment sur les JO pour tous pierre
pierre l'a rappelé donc il faut aussi
que cette communication soit suivie des
faits et que derrière tout le monde
puisse accéder après ils ont beaucoup
communiqué sur les 24 euros surtout dans
leur communication et quand on regarde
le billet vendu moyen et aux alentours
et est à 74 euros voilà il y aura
peut-être un moyen justement de rétablir
un petit peu cet équilibre sur le sur le
cuménisme et puis le le les jeux pour
tous en dehors des places des places
uniques c'est tout ce qui va se faire en
dehors et autour des stades il y aura
sûrement pas de place pour tout le monde
dans les stades ça c'est une évidence
mais par exemple pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture pour laquelle la scène a été
choisie pour être la plus la plus large
possible
c'est sans doute là qu'il vise le côté
universel des jeux avec des accès voilà
qui sont gratuits et qui sont qui sont
beaucoup plus nombreux dans les stades
dans les stades on prenait l'exemple du
vélo dont il y a du vélo de 50 ans de
toute façon le nombre de places est
limitées quand vous qu'on vous rajoutez
les délégations les délégations les
sportifs et les staffs et les staffs il
reste plus beaucoup de place pour les
spectateurs donc
peuplomb peuplomb les abords des stades
et faisons de faisons réellement de ces
jeux de paris les jeux pour tous les
fans il y aura quand même voir le
marathon sur la justement
j'allais venir justement il y a quand
même il y a quand même des sports qui
seront qui sont gratuits dans les
Yvelines on peut se mettre au bord de la
route pour voir le cyclisme sur route
qui devrait passer dans la vallée de
Chevreuse on pourra également voir les
épreuves du marathon qui se dérouleront
à Versailles à Viroflay le VTT sur la
colline de Lancôme au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bénéficieront
de place gratuite ou les spectateurs
seront debout sur les deux sites il y
aura à la fois les tribunes et des
placements libres où on pourra déambuler
sur le site olympique donc on pourra
quand même voir si on est pas tiré au
sort ou si on a pas choisi
ces Jeux Olympiques on pourra aller voir
des épreuves c'est ça le triathlon ça va
être pareil les épreuves de marche on va
aussi pouvoir aller les voir en stade il
va y avoir des choses il y aura des
choses qui seront qui seront possibles
il faut donner la possibilité aux
personnes au moins touchées du bout du
doigt c'est la dernière fois qu'il y a
eu des JO DT à Paris c'était il y a 100
ans donc c'est un événement qu'on
connaîtra peut-être qu'une fois dans une
vie il faut donner l'opportunité à tous
ceux qui veulent le vivre de pouvoir le
vivre même on va dire du bout du doigt
quoi il y aura une nouvelle session de
vente avec les billets à l'unité du 11
mai à la mi-juin il faudra s'inscrire au
tirage au sort entre le 15 mars et le 21
avril on va maintenant passer à notre
troisième thématique elle concerne le
PSG et plus particulièrement l'une de
ces stars Neymar on le sait Ney aime le
football mais aime aussi la fête selon
le confort du Parisien plusieurs
habitants de Bougival commune où vit
Neymar depuis 2017 sont fatigués des
fêtes organisées par leur célèbres
voisins ils se sont plaint notamment
d'une journée d'anniversaire de la star
le 5 février dernier la musique latino a
retenti en début d'après-midi et la fête
s'est terminée aux alentours de minuit
Neymar aurait une amende de 135 euros
une petite réaction suite à cette à la
fête pas forcément à l'avance par
rapport à la fête Jean ouais c'est bien
alors
mais mais j'ai rien quand on se Verseau
mais franchement mais qu'on parle plus
de sport quand ça va dès qu'on parle de
Neymar on parle plus de ces
extravagances de de sa vie privée que de
performance sportive ça ça commence ça
ça quand même c'est vraiment à me courir
sur les haricots parce que
d'entre nous perso ça m'intéresse pas du
tout de savoir s'il a fait du bruit pour
son anniversaire le 5 février et il a la
chance ce soit pour moi son voisin
la musique elle aurait pas elle aurait
pas eu le temps il aurait pas pris ça ça
traîne ça très très gros dans je serai
gentiment de soirée le maire dit qu'on
peut que lui donner 135 € d'amende oui
c'est pas grave
la police
je vais le voir lui dire de baisser un
peu le son gentiment voilà il parle pas
très bien français
mais ça voilà ça me fatigue qu'on parle
je préférais qu'on parle de performances
sportives avec ce garçon que tout c'est
c'est extrav Maga c'est que ce soit
quand il est pas en boîte de nuit il
fout le bout le bouquin chez lui
bon il joue quand au football ce gars
petit réaction virtuelle réaction c'est
c'est je raccroche avec
une interview de Kylian Mbappe entre les
deux matchs
juste après ou justement il fait il fait
une mise au point et et à peine déguisé
et à peine cibler et je pense que je
suis pareil que genre Mathieu de le côté
extra sportif bon m'intéresse moins mais
c'est vrai que il faut il faut il faut
rapporter ce dont on parle là en extra
sportif aux performances de Neymar sur
les 12 derniers mois il a été loin loin
très loin d'être décisif sur la plupart
des matchs où il était aligné quand ils
sont à 3 avec les avec moto star mais il
est pas il est pas il n'arrive pas à la
cheville au niveau de au niveau de
Mbappé voir de Messi d'ailleurs aussi
quand il est en forme et donc on a on a
là l'impression en faisant ce parallèle
là que que le foot n'est plus ne foute
professionnelle n'est plus sa priorité à
Paris à Paris non plus de gagner des
trophées de gagner notamment de leur
permettre de gagner la Ligue des
Champions n'est pas sa priorité et
effectivement là on regarde son petit
nombril sur les réseaux sociaux il se
met en scène avec justement
vous l'avez plus ou moins évoqué après
la défaite contre le en huitième de
finale allez de la Ligue des Champions
Mbappe dit il faut bien manger et bien
dormir le lendemain Neymar a joué au
poker le soir jusqu'à je crois 2h du
matin et à manger dans une célèbre
chaîne de restauration rapide on va voir
l'image qui est qui va s'afficher voilà
avec ses avec ses amis votre avis il y a
du Jarrier incorrigible
mon avis
quand on quitte Barcelone ouais il a mis
capuche quand même
Barcelone et que
qu'on se dit être le meilleur joueur du
monde à cette époque hein je me souviens
il y a 5 ans et que on va tout gagner et
qu'on vient à Paris pour gagner et bien
on met des moyens pour le faire et les
moyens pour le faire je sais qu'il y a
des gens qui n'apprécient peut-être pas
la personne CR7 qui qui a maintenant 36
ou 37 ans 38 ans le 38 ans Ronaldo le
temps passe pour lui aussi on est
d'ailleurs tous les deux en février
j'aurais pu peut-être faire une fête
d'anniversaire en commun
juste on voit deux
ces deux comportements qui sont
totalement différents l'un de l'autre
c'est à dire qu'il y a un il y en a un
qui va avoir justement un
une vie ultra saine et une vie de
sportif de haut niveau et puis il y en a
un autre qui est malheureusement
peut-être trop doué et qui n'a pas la
culture du travail tout simplement
c'est des choses que j'ai rencontré chez
des jeunes qui avaient qui avaient des
facilités
devant l'autre on attend autre chose
d'un aimant sur un terrain de football
que ce qui rend aujourd'hui
sur le fait que non mais édoué ça je
pense que il a il a un talent non mais
il a un talent il a un talent de base
moi c'est un garçon jaune
à côté du sport alors oui c'est pas la
meilleure vie pour un sportif de haut
niveau qu'il aille manger un fast-food
qu'il aille faire un tournoi de poker
jusqu'à tard dans la nuit en soi moi je
m'en fous le seul souci moi que que j'ai
avec toute cette histoire c'est qu'il se
met quand même en scène il se fait
prendre en photo avec les réseaux
sociaux on sait que ça va très vite
est-ce qu'il y a pas de la provocation
aussi juste après l'interview de Mbappe
ou justement Mbappé lui appelle au calme
dans le vestiaire et a dit voilà il
dicte la conduite à tenir pour un pour
un sportif de haut niveau la question
peut se poser maintenant Neymar oui
c'est vrai qu'il a été surexposé de très
jeune très jeune à l'âge de 12 ans quand
il était au Brésil déjà il y avait des
reportages sur lui à 17 ans il était
déjà professionnel on parlait de lui
comme la future grande star du du
football il est peut-être passé à côté
de sa carrière c'est c'est bien dommage
pour bah pour lui pour les pour les
supporters parisiens également mais oui
forcément
il est tranquille lui il est tranquille
il est assuré ses arrières
financièrement il est il peut continuer
de constater que l'achat le gros
investissement fait par par le PSG on
parle de plus de de 200 millions d'euros
à l'époque 2200 122 millions d'euros bah
sont pas au rendez-vous puisque il a
manqué la moitié des matchs et il n'a
pas été décisif dans les grands
rendez-vous c'est justement je pense un
comportement d'enfants gâté très gâté
c'est à dire que je me souviens du
premier match de tout premier match de
Neymar au PSG je crois que c'était à
Rennes et à Guingamp c'était en automne
à Guingamp il fait alors c'est Guingamp
ok en face il fait un match de folie
c'est-à-dire que là effectivement on
s'est dit ok on a on a investi on a un
vesti lourd on a on a le résultat je
crois qu'il fait il fait deux passes
décisives il plante il plante il plante
un des un des buts donc il fait vraiment
un très très gros match au fur et à
mesure je n'ai jamais vu refaire une
prestation comme celle-là
particulièrement en Ligue des Champions
ça c'est particulièrement absent et il
se comporte comme quelqu'un à qui on a
tout donné trop vite trop tôt sans doute
doué naturellement et qui n'a plus si
tenter qu'il ait eu un jour le sens de
l'effort Philippe moi je suis d'accord
je suis d'accord avec vous monsieur
régulièrement au Parc des Princes mais
ce qu'on vous avait tout dit sur Neymar
ces folies tout ça et moi je ce que je
trouve par rapport à Bougival comme
c'était au départ il habite Bougival que
en fin de compte à Bougival ils
connaissent pas les gamins qui jouent
dans le club de Bougival qui joue dans
les qui jouent dans les clubs à côté ils
le voient pas moi je pense qu'au lieu de
se montrer sur les réseaux sociaux
fast-food enfin et cetera et cetera il
irait dans les clubs dans le club déjà
de Bougival il irait voir les enfants
voir tout ça je pense que déjà même le
maire tout ça il serait ça fait le même
nom français quasiment il n'a pas été du
tout dans au club de Bougival et et
ailleurs donc hein
donc pour moi c'est ça autrement vous
avez tout dit mais là en plus il est
prolongé il a été prolongé jusqu'en 2027
donc en fin de compte 2002 il aura 35
ans 2025
personne n'en veut mais personne
personne n'en veut après il y a un truc
que je voulais juste rajouter aussi à la
rigueur il va vous chauffer au er fast
food il peut c'est pas un souci moi je
Michael Phelps vous souvenez vous avouez
un petit peu
de vingtaine de médailles d'or olympique
voilà
mais le mec mangeait des pizzas et
manger des burgers et il le disait Sean
Paul toi aussi je crois dans mes
souvenirs manger beaucoup de nuggets
apparemment
sauf que
quand il faut être présent les gars ils
sont là il y a pas de problème à la
Coupe du Monde on n'est pas blessés ils
sont pro quand on est aux JO et ben
ouais il y a une semaine où on est dans
les bassins tous les jours et on assure
mais il y a pas de souci et ça veut dire
que en amont et ben on a travaillé aussi
pour pouvoir arriver au niveau auquel
ils sont oui ils sont des gens qui sont
doués mais en plus qu'ils travaillent
Grégory c'est que derrière l'institution
Paris Saint-Germain elle est pas assez
forte je regrette même si c'est une
superstar qu'au niveau marketing
forcément Neymar va attirer beaucoup de
femmes autour du PSG le PSG alors c'est
pas pour moins que ça il y a quand même
eu des insultes mais à l'époque de la
Ferrari avait sévit très vite pour ser
janvier là on parle quand même d'un
manque de professionnels assez récurrent
des absences aussi prolongées plutôt que
de le prolonger et de lui garantir un
salaire le PSG aurait dû s'en séparer là
ça montre aussi peut-être les feuilles
derrière en institution on a peut-être
pas assez on va dire de poignes pour
dire à Neymar que il ne peut pas se
comporter ainsi il est dans un club qui
veut gagner des titres qui veut gagner
la Ligue des Champions c'était
l'objectif affiché aujourd'hui c'est
toujours pas arrivé il faut que aussi le
PSG c'est bizarre et je pense que ça
prouve peut-être la faiblesse de
l'institution rapidement avant de passer
la prochaine thématique
quand on veut changer et prendre des
bonnes habitudes c'est juste 21 jours
pendant 21 jours vous faites la même
chose
tous les jours et au bout d'un moment ça
devenait ça va devenir un automatisme
donc Neymar ne doit pas faire la fête
pendant 21 jours
mais non mais je pense que je pense que
c'est un problème d'éducation très
rapidement avant de refermer cette page
Neymar doit-il quitter le PSG très
rapidement
la gamelle est très très belle
ça c'est sûr bon on va maintenant parler
à basket est un joueur qui est aussi
convoité que notre Grégory canalet
national je veux bien sûr parler de
Victor web banyama livinois originaire
du chinero concours qui mesure
va signer en NBA cette année il va
sûrement terminer le numéro 1 pas de
draft il a donné une interview
dernièrement le confrères de France
Télévisions où il dit je ne veux pas
devenir un joueur lambda de NBA il dit
qu'il vise plus haut et mais veut
marquer l'histoire la question sur cette
thématique est-il trop ambitieux oui ou
non
oui non
vous êtes le seul le seul partagé alors
du coup pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes
partagés il est trop ambitieux en fait
c'est d'afficher ces ambitions alors oui
ça le change on ça nous change de Victor
webmanyama qui était plutôt discret ces
dernières années il est encore très
jeune c'est aussi c'est aussi pour ça et
c'est vrai que là de sortie au jour avec
voilà de poser ses ambitions et dire je
ne veux pas devenir un joueur lambda bah
bien sûr mais nous aussi on veut pas
qu'il devienne un joueur lambda de NBA
maintenant de l'afficher aussitôt avant
même d'avoir été dans cette draft voilà
avant même d'avoir été recruté par un
club de NBA et ce qui s'avance et ce qui
met la charrue avant les bœufs je
suis en droit de me le demander un peu
en arrière parce que il a dit qu'en fin
de compte il y a d'abord la le
championnat du championnat du monde
avant que il ferait tout pour les
championnats du monde et il est revenu
un peu il est revenu un peu en arrière
tu vois par rapport à la NBA je suis
content quand même de le voir aussi
ambitieux mais je pense qu'il peut-être
s'avance trop vite j'aurais aimé qu'il
soit déjà dans le championnat de NBA qui
fasse quelques matchs et qui montre
qu'il a ce talent qu'on qu'on reconnaît
tous hein mais qui doit être prouvé
aussi au niveau international et là à ce
moment-là j'aurais accepté une telle
trop vite selon vous peut-être un peu
trop vite c'est pas aussi le fait que
LeBron James par cœur tous les grands
noms aussi le le disque le disque c'est
un phénomène que c'est je trouve que
aussi il est il est un peu porté il est
porté en plus par les grands joueurs
quand même il est porté donc en fin de
compte tu vois ils disent plus que c'est
une licorne c'est une licorne qui
l'appelle enfin c'est quand même c'est
quand même incroyable aussi pour un
jeune est-ce qu'il croit pas en lui-même
finalement
il doit le faire il doit il doit croire
en ses compétences on s'efforce ce qui
me fait répondre non il n'est pas trop
ambitieux c'est deux raisons la première
c'est que je pense que naturellement il
ne sera jamais un joueur lambda c'est
c'est mensurations ces mensurations sont
là ça
et pour le coup qu'il voit loin avec
ambition je pense pas qu'il a la grosse
tête pour le pour autant mais c'est une
c'est une bonne chose c'est une bonne
chose et je pense que la NBA va
récupérer une pépite va nous le formater
et quand on le récupérera avec l'équipe
de France ça sera un tout bon
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je dis souvent
la lune il faut viser les étoiles il y
est déjà lui dans les étoiles
donc voilà c'est à dire que il faut pas
se fixer des limites et ensuite
quand pour devenir un grand champion
faut avoir un ego surdimensionné on
n'est pas c'est on n'est pas on n'est
pas cristal neuronaldo si justement on
n'est pas hyper confiant dans ce que
l'on dans en soi et dans ce que l'on met
en place donc je suis en effet peut-être
c'est un petit peu tôt il aurait
peut-être pu le dire une fois qu'il ait
eu des premiers résultats en NBA
maintenant il annonce la couleur et bien
peut-être qu'il va être capable de
mettre les choses en place pour pouvoir
obtenir ces résultats par la suite
joueur lambda c'est pas non plus bisous
je rejoins parce que ce que ce qui a été
dit jusqu'à présent il est tellement
sollicité ce garçon actuellement que là
on va dire que c'est sa première
peut-être petite faute entre guillemets
une petite qui l'a reconnu de suite tout
de suite et puis il est revenu dessus
donc on le pousse tellement à être à
être ce qui n'est pas encore sur le plan
de la NBA puisqu'il y a pas encore mis
les pieds mais on le pousse tellement on
attend tellement de ce garçon
que je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de
lucidité pour justement pas prendre la
grosse tête parce que vraiment on en
fait déjà une une immense star
américaine avant même qui qui qui l'ai
mis des pieds alors quoi qu'il arrive
mais quand il sera numéro 1 il sera
millionnaire et l'avantage qu'il a c'est
qu'il est quand même reconnu par ses
paires et parler pas les plus grandes de
ce sport actuellement puisque nous
sommes là on va voir jouer voilà ou
quelque part il est il a la lucidité et
d'avoir de l'ambition quand on a
l'utilité quand on a plus on a la classe
ben moi je trouve que c'est tout à fait
logique et heureusement qu'il en a pas
ce serait ce serait quand même un comble
qu'il n'est pas la lucidité de dire bon
je vais y aller voir ce que c'est puis
bah non il veut il veut il veut être il
veut il veut devenir le meilleur joueur
et ben il a l'air les moyens tout le
monde dit que c'est c'est un futur très
grand et bien moi je dis bravo qui
continue comme ça
fait deux trois ans que nous en plateau
on parle de lui
10 cm petit
euh
ça fait trois saisons ça fait quand même
déjà un moment faut pas oublier que
quand on commence à peine à en parler ça
pourrait déjà être fini c'est à dire que
n'importe quel blessure aurait pu faire
enfin pas n'importe quelle voiture mais
une blessure on va faire sa carrière
elle aurait déjà pu être fini donc là ça
fait 3 ans le garçon commence à à
affoler les les compteurs je et moi je
me souviens des premiers matchs qui
faisait ou en effet quand il est marqué
6-8 points bah et non et finalement ben
voilà là ça y est c'est parti il
commence à enfin même pas comment
d'ailleurs il maintient cette il est
déjà il est déjà en place bah voilà
maintenant la prochaine étape
c'est l'année prochaine c'est la NBA et
elle lui tend les bras est-ce que ça
vous fait peur ou pas pour les blessures
pour pour lui on voit il est quand même
assez fin encore bon même si il commence
à prendre un petit peu en gabarit
j'ai dit on commence à dire attention il
est quand même grand et généralement les
grands NBA ça fait c'est bien sur le
moment mais ça dure pas forcément pour
un exemple de yaomi qui est le célèbre
le célèbre chinois qui faisait 2 m 29 on
le voit à l'image tu avais quasiment pas
besoin de sauter pour pour toucher le
prématuré le cercle il a dû arrêter
assez jeune il a il a décliné à partir
de 28 ans il a arrêté à 30 ans qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez il faut faire il faut
qu'il fasse attention
en étant drafté je pense que il fera
attention et il faut qu'il soit bien
conseillé et je pense
la famille toujours autour
ça vous fait pas peur les blessures
évidemment c'est c'est c'est l'épée de
Damoclès donc on participement sur ce
plateau quelle que soit les sports et là
moi c'est ce que je disais c'est c'est
il est il fait ces deux mètres 21 je le
trouve plutôt fin mais il a 19 ans donc
après il faut depuis 2 ans il faut il
faut faire gaffe à la partie à la partie
musculation croissance et en gros être
capable d'encaisser les matchs de NBA
qui sont un plus nombreux et deux sur un
autre intensité que sur une période
courte aussi la NBA ça joue pas pendant
ça joue pas aussi longtemps que que la
que la proie par exemple c'est c'est
mais tu joues tu joues beaucoup tu joues
ouais tu joues régulièrement
mais nous on a quand même l'impression
plutôt son problème de blessure il était
très blessé sur les saisons précédentes
quand il a joué à Nanterre ou du côté de
l'ASVEL là cette saison on a
l'impression que c'est que c'est rentré
un peu plus dans l'ordre peut-être parce
que la musculation
il fait plus de sieste par exemple il
s'organise mieux au niveau de sa journée
il se couche plus je crois à partir de
au-delà de 23h23h30 alors qu'avant il le
faisait et il se blesse quasiment plus
il a Vincent collé à ses côtés qui est
aussi le sexuelle de l'équipe de France
donc il est bien entouré et c'est vrai
oui l'entourage aussi joue un rôle
primordial et ses parents voilà
peut-être le maintien encore un peu un
peu sur terre c'est vrai que moi j'étais
surpris je leur dis encore par cette
voilà cette prise de position il s'est
il s'est affirmé mais on attend qu'il
s'affirme quand même aussi le Victor
ouais
je veux pas je veux pas être un joueur
lambda sur l'échelle de Neymar peut-être
voilà là il est tout propre tout en bas
0,5 alors on va maintenant on va passer
à l'envolée de Grégory un moment unique
dans cette émission qu'on découvre à
chaque fois alors de quoi allez-vous
nous parler à Grégory on a de la chance
que l'on a comme journaliste Mickael de
couvrir parfois des des événements de
beaux événements pour vous on peut
peut-être citer la rider Cup dans les
événements sportifs ils ont découvert
deux hein
j'ai une petite préférence quand même
pour la France finalement
et championnats du monde de 50 ans de
beaux événements moi je me rappelle mon
CV la saison dernière
match de Bergerac face à Versailles
c'était le quart de finale de la Coupe
de France de football il y en a un autre
moi que je mettrai dans mon top 10 on va
dire des événements que j'ai pu couvrir
dans ma jeune carrière de journaliste
alors c'est l'histoire d'une rivalité
entre deux lycées de Versailles et d'un
côté cinq Geneviève que l'on nommera
dans cette histoire Ginette de l'autre
Hoche depuis 17 ans les établissements
en règle en quelque sorte leur compte
dans un match de basket entre les élèves
de prépa une parenthèse sportive dans
leur cursus difficile ou les moments à
pour souffler son rat je être honnête
nickel quand au début vous m'avez parlé
de venir couvrir cet événement avec vous
un match de basket entre deux classes de
prépa bon ça va pas tout de suite
emballer mais je me suis laissé tenter
je vous ai suivis emporter emporté par
ma curiosité et voilà c'est ça mon
premier titre
vous savez être très persuasif alors mon
premier ginettage c'était la l'année
dernière et là grosse surprise dans ce
gymnase Montbauron l'impression d'être
tombé en pleine scène d'High School
Musical le match de basket certes mais
surtout autour des tribunes pleines de
supporters déchaînés un maître de
cérémonie un DJ de renom la prestation
des cheerleaders des deux lycées bref le
temps d'une soirée je me suis retrouvé
en plein campus américain pour avoir
assisté à de nombreux rendez-vous
sportifs en salle j'ai vu pareil
ambiance de rares occasions même les
guests qui viennent sur ce Ginette Hoche
dont le parrain vice-président
vice-président vie champion olympique je
sais pas pourquoi je voulais dire
président mais vice champion
d'un club voilà mais vice champion de
basket Fred Weiss qui reconnaît que
l'atmosphère y est unique extraordinaire
bref j'ai bien fait de vous suivre
Michael sur sur ce coup-là cette année
rebelote on a même reçu les capitaines
des deux équipes l'organisateur de
l'événement également François lamans
sur sur ce plateau ça se chambray
gentiment en plateau les taquineries ce
sont poursuivis également sur le terrain
ou les supporters de Ginette avaient
pris pour cible capitaine de Hoche
Antoine après le succès du lycée Hoche
la saison dernière c'est le lycée
Sainte-Geneviève qui a remis les
pendules à l'heure cette année en
s'imposant 47 à 38 l'établissement mène
désormais 15 à 2 au bilan des
confrontations mais l'essentiel est
ailleurs j'ai envie de dire l'ambiance à
une nouvelle fois été au rendez-vous
1300 spectateurs dans ce gymnase
Montbron les champs ont laissé place à
quelques surprises notamment pour la
première fois un concours de dunk avec
la présence du champion de France de la
discipline Ginette Hoche c'est un
événement qui prend de l'ampleur on a pu
constater Mickaël cette année avec la
présence de
les médias des médias comme France
Télévisions qui ont consacré à un
reportage sur sur cet événement une
reconnaissance méritée j'ai envie de
dire aussi un point bel événement qui
peut-être sera ouvert un jour au grand
public parce que pour le moment c'est
réservé aux spectateurs des deux lycées
un ginetteoche pourquoi pas dans une
salle de plus grande envergure et avec
des guests dans les gradins encore plus
de guest les organisateurs espèrent dès
l'an prochain avoir un certain tenu par
cœur
je vous ai dit un c'est le moment que
l'on savoure dans cette émission
il a travaillé il a énormément travaillé
sur cette envolée en plus voilà vous
avez essayé parler votre cœur et aussi
une double page aussi dans l'équipe qui
a été faite sur le match Ginette Hoche
donc une couverture médiatique qui prend
de plus en plus d'ampleur au fur et à
mesure des années alors votre avis sur
cette envolée sur ce duel entre Ginette
et Hoche
vous validez et je pense que il en
faudrait plus il en faudrait plus c'est
à dire que après les organisateurs ne
veulent pas non non
qui est ce duel mais je pense que HEC
peut avoir la même chose avec d'autres
grandes écoles sur le plateau de Saclay
il peut y avoir plus et puis parce que
là en effet moi j'ai faim j'ai la chance
peut-être d'avoir pu participer à des
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste devant
beaucoup beaucoup de monde je vous
assure que c'est des souvenirs qui
restent impérissables quand le vélo de
Rome était plein il y avait 5000
personnes plus
c'était un chaud c'était pas c'était pas
une épreuve mais ça n'empêche que
l'ambiance les gens qui crient etc c'est
les choses que que nous comme on ne le
vit pas au quotidien mais c'est génial
d'ailleurs du match ça donne ça donne de
l'espoir sur le de combler le retard
qu'on a par exemple sur la culture
sportive universitaire et scolaire aux
États-Unis par exemple et ça ce type
d'événement et je crois que c'est le
seul
donne de l'espoir sur la considération
qu'on peut avoir pour le sport dans dans
les dans les Hautes Études parce que en
gros eux tous ces étudiants là de ces
deux établissements c'est une petite
parenthèse dans leur année où ils
cravache comme des grands prépa comme
des comme des sourds et des sourdes
parce que c'est mixtes aussi le match
mixte et c'est c'est pour le coup je
pense une vraie une vraie lueur d'espoir
pour pour la considération la prise en
compte du sport dans les cursus
universitaires et scolaires et puis ça
donne du ça donne du ça donne du
spectacle ça donne des étoiles partout
alors oui c'est un peu amateur pour
faire comme les américains avec la Kiska
mon carton et puis des cheerleaders qui
ont peut-être que quelques semaines pour
s'entraîner pour s'entraîner mais ça
mérite une plus grande salle et ça
mérite effectivement comme le disait
Yann que ça que ça transpire un petit
peu plus dans d'autres sports dans
d'autres écoles dans d'autres
universités et d'autres écoles même chez
le plus jeune d'ailleurs aussi parce que
parce que rien ne remplace un soutien
populaire derrière des sportifs
notamment dans des équipes que les
dernières à la ville de Palaiseau mes
enfants sont à l'école ils ont fait des
journées sportives mais les gamins c'est
les 300 gamins je par jour et quand on
donnait leur nom des com ou qui avait un
de leurs copains tes qualifié pour une
finale mais c'était et en effet c'était
génial d'entendre ces gamins crier et le
cross annuel c'est le c'est le Graal il
faut gagner le cross annuel c'est et
donc en effet il y a ces essences et tu
as raison il faut les on a ces essences
et bien il faut les faire nourrir pour
que le sport prenne plus de place dans
notre dans notre culture genre ça vous
plaît un match comme ça oui mais c'est
très bien c'est très dans l'esprit et
cet engouement et cet état d'esprit qui
peut régner ces manifestations c'est
fabuleux alors j'ai connu ça pour les
anciens quand vous êtes UNSS mais
l'ancien a su je constate le rugby quand
on avait le l'établissement je me
souviens avoir fait justement une finale
de championnat de France avec
établissement l'engouement qui avait
derrière tous les élèves de de
l'établissement qui venait supporter
parce qu'à l'époque c'était un match
voilà une finale contre établissement
d'une autre ville et ça avait été mais
ça avait été exactement la même ambiance
cette ambiance
conviviale
avec avec mais même en tant que joueur
et pourtant moi à l'époque je jouais
déjà je jouais déjà au rugby de 22 ans
pas mal de spectateurs mais même même
mais c'est super vous sentez quand même
une chaleur et puis du coup vous faites
partie ça fait un peu le système
américain je reviens je me disais pierre
c'est qu'on fait partie un petit peu des
des pseudos stars de l'établissement
quoi vous êtes fait partie de l'équipe
qui était dans ce match là par exemple
Antoine guidon qui était le capitaine de
Hosh j'avais le droit de son tifo du
côté de Ginette où il a marqué guidon tu
dérailles par exemple
voilà les deux équipes il y avait même
le portrait d'un d'un autre sportif
aussi qui était
accrochés
les affiches ils mettent pas trop tôt
parce que parce que ils étaient avant
ils étaient comment voler et maintenant
il est vendent maintenant ils vendent
les affiches donc ils se font du blé par
personne c'est bien tout est bien et ils
sont 150 je crois organiser ça c'est pas
mal on va regarder un extrait justement
et on revient juste après
forcément déçu forcément déçu forcément
le sentiment d'avoir raté quelque chose
tous ces Pen on a été très prolifique on
a été plus politiques que Ginette t'as
perdu mais c'est en terme de réalisme le
réalisme il a pas été là nous on a été
prolifique bordel on a été pour les
filles et l'ambiance et l'ambiance
manette là là moins de personnes plus
ambiance qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai plus besoin
qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe regardez on la défaite on
l'accepte la défaite on l'accepte mais
honnêtement c'était formidable c'était
très bien merci
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ça va il y
a une bonne ambiance dans ce match
et c'est vrai que on va du coup mais il
va pas y avoir doliganisme dans ces
rencontres là et tout le monde va
pouvoir porter
sur le terrain on va regarder justement
un moment de de communion dans ce dans
ce match pendant dans cette soirée hein
parce que c'est bien plus qu'un match on
va regarder un extrait on revient juste
après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Grégory
c'était bien et je tiens à souligner
c'est une italienne qui fait soulever
tous ces jeunes parce que même si le
titre est en anglais
[Rires]
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
de Neymar le footballeur du
Paris-Saint-Germain le vrai courage
c'est le poursuivre ses rêves même quand
tout le monde dit que c'est impossible
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]